nous sommes en 2001 sur cette île de la
Méditerranée à cet endroit des
archéologues découvrent une tombe
humaine très ancienne ils y trouvent des
restes de haamp Pierre quelques
coquillages un silex et puis à quelques
dizaines de centimètres apparaissent les
os d'un petit animal je galopee comme un
fou j'arrive et je vois les gars qui
était en train de commencer à ramasser
des eau qui avait pas compris
l'importance de ce qu'il trouvait donc
j'ai arrêté tout parce que je sais que
quand on dépose un animal complet dans
une tombe ça a un sens cette découverte
ça semble être le plus ancien chat de
compagnie connu des scientifiques et ça
ça a participé à révolutionner la
compréhension d'un de nos plus fidèles
animaux domestiques salut c'est Lucas
des chats comme celui-ci vous en avez
peut-être un chez vous et récemment je
me suis demandé comment on est passé
d'un félin sauvage et solitaire comme
celui-là par exemple à ce compagnon qui
partage des millions de foyers avec nous
à travers le monde cette histoire vous
allez voir elle diffère fortement de
celle d'autres animaux domestiques comme
le chien par exemple le chat est entré
finalement en relation avec l'homme sans
qu'il y ait une volonté particulière ni
de l'homme ni du chat il va y avoir pas
mal de remondissement et ça en dit
beaucoup sur nos chats actuels notamment
sur la taille de leur cerveau pour ce
nouvel épisode de la grande explication
j'ai creusé quelles origines se cachent
derrière notre chat domestique comment
et pourquoi il est devenu l'un de nos
compagnons je vous
explique des chats domestiques dans le
monde il y en aurait près de 600
millions selon le Muséum national
d'histoire naturel pourtant si on
remonte le temps bien avant l'an zé il
existe une époque où il n'y en avait
aucun
le début de cette histoire est longtemps
resté un mystère nos races de chats
est-ce qu'elles viennent d'ancêtres
différents ou alors d'un seul ancêtre et
du coup lequel dans la nature en effet
il existe des dizaines d'espèces de
petit félins et même chez les chats
sauvages ce qui se rapproche le plus des
chats domestiques il existe par exemple
le chat horné en Asie centrale le chat
forestier en Europe le chat ganté au
Moyen-Orient et en Afrique du Nord ou
encore le chat sauvage d'Afrique
subsaharienne c'est seulement en 2009
que des études génétiques montrent que
les chats domestiques descendent tous
d'un seul et même chat sauvage le chat
ganté c'est un chat comme on les rêve
mais plus élancé plus grand plus
puissant que nos chats domestiques ou
que la plupart de nos chats domestiques
c'est une espèce qui vit encore
aujourd'hui dans la nature vivant donc
dans cette zoneel à l'état sauvage c'est
lui qui va donner naissance à tous les
chats domestiques et ça ça a commencé il
y a très
longtemps nous sommes autour de Mo- 3500
avant Jésus-Christ en Chine du Nord dès
cette époque des chats vivent auprès des
humains le chien c'était l'animal
domestique des chasseurs moi j'ai
rajouté que le chat c'était l'animal
domestique des agriculteur remontons
autour de Mo- 3700 nous sommes à des
milliers de kilomètres de la Chine en
Égypte antique des chats sont notamment
enterré dans le cimetière princier de la
cité de hierraacompolis ici aussi des
chats vont partager la vie de
différentes sociétés égyptiennes et
cette domestication dont on a des traces
dans les célèbres cites égyptiens et là
on trouve des momis de chats donc on
voit bien que le chat avait un statut
très particulier elles sont vendues à
des pèlerins en faitin donc on élève des
chats on les massacre de manière
horrible et sans aucun respect des
animaux on fabrique des momies pour les
vendre à des pèlerins allons encore 5000
ans avant ça autour de moins 8800 cette
fois sur l'île de Chipre les chats sont
présents dans des villages Chypre c'est
une île qui est qui a surgi du fond des
océans il y a pas d'ancêtre du chat à
Chypre donc dès qu'on trouve des oses de
chat dans un site archéologique ça veut
dire qu'il a été introduit du continent
on imagine bien que un chat à 70 km de
Brass foulé entre le continent et chip
c'est pas très vraisemblable donc ça
veut dire qu'on a introduit des chats
donc ça veut dire qu'on avait une
relation avec le chat et ce qui m'a
fasciné c'est qu'à ces trois endroits
donc Chypre la Chine et l'Égypte les
chats seraient venu de même vers les
humains pour les mêmes raisons quand les
humains ont commencé à développer
l'agriculture ou qui se sont installés
dans les premiers villages parmi les
premières bêtes qui trouvent une source
de nourriture dans ces villages et ben
il y a les petites c'est-à-dire les
moineau et les souris et en particulier
ce qui va avec la souris c'est le chat
qui est l'un des principaux prédateurs
donc ils vont suivre naturellement puis
tout ça ça forme un ménage à tro si on
peut dire avec les humains et les
humains finalement vont tolérer la
présence du chat qui est pourtant un
animal assez sauvage le chat va
s'habituer à la présence des humains
parce qu'il a tout intérêt il y a plein
à manger et puis les liens vont se tissé
Jean don vigne il a trouvé une trace
particulière qui démontre bien les
premières relations
chumain nous sommes autour de Mo- 7000
de nouveau sur l'île de Chypre et plus
précisément dans le village néolithique
de chiloro Cambos c'est ici qu'on trouve
cette sépulture abritant un homme et un
chat à ses côtés cette découverte est
faite en 2001 lors de fouille organisé
par l'archéologue Jean Guilen pour qu'on
se projette un peu mieux j'ai demandé à
des intelligences artificielles de
dessiner ce à quoi ça pouvait
ressembler bon vu le résultat je vais
plutôt laisser Jean Denis vigne qui a
participé à cette découverte vous
expliquer ce qu'il en retient le chat et
l'homme sont complets se regarde si on
peut dire mais ça aussi c'est c'est une
vue de l'esprit hein mais ils sont
disposés d'une certaine manière on peut
en tirer la la conclusion qu'il y avait
une relation privilégiée entre cet
homme-là ce chat-là est-ce que cette
relation elle était réelle dans la vie
de tous les jours oui très probablement
parce qu'on a en analysant le squelette
du chat on a montré que c'est un jeune
chat qui a été mieux nourri que les
autres on peut imaginer qu'on a mis dans
la tombe une représentation d'une
relation finalement de de domesticité le
mot qui nous vient c'est c'est animal de
compagnie hein mais à Chypre puis plus
tard en Égypte ou en Chine comme on l'a
dit comment a-t-on pu franchir cette
étape com on est passé de premier
contact assez simple entre chat humain à
une relation de proximité beaucoup plus
forte il y a un lien important qui va
être finalement le passage à une
complicité domestique c'est-à-dire
finalement que certains chats soi
peut-être un peu apprivoisé ou adopté
quand il s'agit de chaton par les
enfants et cetera il évidment très
rapidement ça doit se tisser tout ça
l'étape d'après pour le chat domestique
c'est de conquérir le reste du
monde là il va y avoir voir en gros
trois grandes étapes à partir d'environ
Mo- 5000 une première vague de chats
arrive progressivement en Europe de
l'Est ces chats ils viennent du Proche
Orient avec les premiers groupes humains
néolithiques qui apportent notamment
l'agriculture est-ce qu'ils étaient
pleinement domestiques ou est-ce qu'ils
vivaient dans les villages est-ce que
les gens avaient compris que c'était
important de les emporter avec eux ou
est-ce que ils ont suivi un petit peu
naturellement on sait pas mais en tout
cas on les trouve ces chats on les
trouve nourris pas seulement de souris
mais aussi de reste de la consommation
humaine une deuxième phase a lieu à
l'Antiquité depuis l'Égypte au fil des
siècles certains chats gardent un rôle
de chasseur de souris notamment sur
certains bateaux mais on retrouve aussi
à différentes époques le rôle d'animal
de compagnie en témoin notamment cette
image du cardinal de Richelieu
représenté avec plusieurs de ses chats à
sa mort ce ministre du roi Louis XI en
avait 14 enfin il y a une troisième
phase quand les Européens apportent le
chat dans les continents éloignés avec
leurs navires partout où finalement les
civilisations occidental vont euh
s'implanter ben elles vont entraîner
avec elle le chat tout à l'heure je vous
ai dit que des traces de domestication
de chat avait aussi été retrouvé en
Chine il y a très longtemps c'était à
partir d'un autre chat sauvage le chat
léopard mais cette lignée semble s'être
éteinte ce qu'on y trouve aujourd'hui
descendent plutôt de chats àortés plus
tard d'Europe ou du proche- Orient
notamment via les routes de la soie il
reste encore une question fondamentale
d'un seul chat domestique à la base
comment on est arrivé aux dizaines de
races qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui ce chat au poil Milon il
fait partie de l'une des plus anciennes
races de chat c'est le chat angora
turque et comme son nom l'indique il est
originaire de Turquie il est emporté en
Europe dès le 17e siècle mais la plupart
des autres races de chat elles sont bien
plus récentes les races elles
apparaissent pas comme ça toutes seules
c'est c'est les humains qui les ont créé
en faisant des
croisements et en s'amusant d'une
certaine manière et en fait ça ça date
de la fin du 19e et du courant du 20e
siècle par exemple le premier standard
de la race chat européen remonte
seulement à 1925 cette race elle a été
créée à partir des chats qui étaient
présents sur le continent d'autres races
sont obtenues en croisant des chats
domestiques avec d'autres espèce de
félin sauvage c'est le cas du chat
Bengal actuel il est issu d'un
croisement entre le chat domestique et
le chat léopard certains de ces hybrides
comme le Savan sont d'ailleurs interdits
dans certains pays comme je vous l'avais
expliqué dans cette vidéo aujourd'hui il
existe plus d'une soixantaine de races
officielles de chats domestique plus
globalement voyons ce que ça a changé de
passer d'un animal sauvage à domestique
pour eux mais également pour nous
cette domestication on peut dire qu'elle
a apporté des bénéfices aux humains
notamment la chasse d'animaux comme les
soris ou les liens affectifs selon
jeandenis Vig cela a aussi permis aux
descendants du Chag ganté de prospérer
bien plus qu'ils auraient pu le faire
naturellement mais cela a aussi changer
la donne pour d'autres animaux il
continuent à se nourrir d'oiseaux et
puis d'un certain nombre d'espèces même
de reptilesun certain nombre d'espèces
qui sont en voie de disparition et pour
lesquels met une pression tout à fait
néfaste pour le pour la biodiversité la
domestication elle a aussi transformé le
châle lui-même même si à première vue il
est pas forcément facile de voir
certaines différences ils ont une
abondance de nourriture à disposition
donc d'une certaine manière ils perdent
un certain nombre de compétences et on
le voit très bien d'ailleurs le volume
du cerveau dès le début de la
domestication il est réduit ils ont plus
la nécessité de se focaliser sur une
chasse extrêmement difficile il y a pas
que la modification du pelage ou la
taille et il y a des comportements
nouveaux chez le chat en 2019 des
scientifiques de l'Université d'Helsinki
ont cherché à répartir des races de
chats selon leur personnalité ce groupe
1 compte notamment le siamois et
l'Européen en comparaison les races du
groupe 2 sont moins craintives moins
extraverties et moins agressives on y
trouve par exemple le ragdll et le
perçant le groupe 3 avec le Bengal par
exemple est plus craintif et plus
extraverti enfin le dernier groupe est
plus agressif on y retrouve notamment
l'angora turque la création des races de
chat par l'humain a donc fait naître en
plus des différences physiques des
différences de comportement et en
particulier le miaolement le
ronronnement qui sont des sons que le
que les chats peuvent émettre les chats
sauvages peuvent émettre quand ils sont
très jeunes mais qui disparaissent dans
la vie adulte donc dans la nouvelle vie
de ces chats qui deviennent domestiques
finalement se développe un langage
particulier pour communiquer avec
l'homme mais d'une certaine manière nous
ne parlons pas non plus à nos chats
comme nous parlons entre nous humains
donc nous avons aussi développé un
langage nous avons aussi développ des
[Musique]
comportements j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu n'hésitez pas à pororter vos
compléments ou à poser vos questions en
commentaire voici un petit bonus c'est
une comparaison supplémentaire entre la
domestication des chats et celle des
chiens don compare par exemple la grande
diversité des races de chiens par
rapport à l'ancêtre le loup c'est
immense entre les chihuahua et puis les
les les Dogs et
ceteraon chez les chats il y a quand
même pas une diversité aussi forte parce
qu'il y a cette finalement cette moindre
plasticité biologique mais aussi ce fait
que on n jamais sélectionné un chat pour
ne pas mordre alors que des chiens on
les sélectionne pour pas mordre un chat
qui aurait une des dents aussi peu
développé qu'un
chihuahua bah il pourrait pas il
pourrait pas attraper de souris il
pourrait pas les consommer il pourrait
pas se nourrir en dehors de l'homme un
grand merci à Jean Denine pour les
histoires passionnantes qu'il m'a
raconté pour plus de vidéo vous pouvez
vous abonner à brut sur notre chaîne
vous pourrez par exemple retrouver la
grande explication sur le chat Savana et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouvel épisode